Speaker 1: Let's go next to Roland from Vienna.
Is that Vienna, Austria?
Speaker 3: That it is, David, can you hear
me,
Speaker 1: I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: Perfect.
Yes, yes, yes, I agree with the previous caller,
I don't think it's because they that's the
only way they can formulate their thoughts,
but the Republicans, the right wing in general,
as we have over here, they speak the language
of the internet much better and they know
it.
They know to use it to fold their their listeners
better than it left us.
Speaker 1: No, I think you're right.
I think you're right.
Speaker 3: Listen, I called in once before
and I dropped an F-bomb, I want to excuse
myself for that because you asked me the question
about whether I like cappuccinos.
And I quoted I quoted Jimi from Philly.
It said, If you're your cappuccino.
Right.
So which brings me to my first point I want
to congratulate for you for a piece you brought
out in the summer with doctor and I'm blanking
on his name where you talked with the doctor
and with Jimmy from Filipo Daugunu.
Speaker 1: Dr. Alok Kenosha.
Speaker 3: And that man is a hero.
I listen to some of the other stuff he does
with these kids online.
Yes.
Great and very revealing.
Very revealing about the motivation for where
Jimmy comes from.
Yeah, think so.
That's one point I want to make two points,
the first one being how Putin seems to be.
We know Trump loves them.
We know Fox News sides with him.
Yes.
Are these guys aware that whenever there's
a mass shooting in Russia?
There's an assault rifle ban.
Speaker 1: They probably are not aware of
that, no.
Speaker 3: They should be Putin is one of
the toughest guys on gun control because he
knows the only way to control the population
is when they don't have one with.
They always say no.
So it's really ridiculous to see how they're
falling in love with him when in reality he's
pushing a lot of things that they're not comfortable
with.
Well, it's
Speaker 1: ridiculous for a lot of reasons,
and you've just added one more
Speaker 3: thing.
Yeah.
And I see a lot of people asking you to go
back on Joe Rogan and to tell him what's up.
And I think from a general perspective, I
fully agree with that.
I stopped listening, to be honest, I was never
a big fan.
Anyway, I'm in standup comedy, so that was
a good way to get the news of the day in that
field.
But he's hence a persona non grata in my podcast
feed.
Wow.
And specifically because this is something
that he always pushes.
So I'm from Austria, I'm smack in the middle
of Europe.
We have socialized health care.
All the countries around us do.
We're quite happy with it.
And I always hear.
From a lot of conservatives, Republicans and
all the enemy guys on Joe Rogan, everyone's
like, Oh, if you're in if you're in Europe
and you break your leg, you need to wait months
to get it fixed.
Well, yes, if you if you want to get it fixed
socialized health care that that pays for
itself, then you may you may be on a waiting
spot.
That's that's true.
Speaker 1: But I'm guessing you're you're
not going to need to wait months to be stabilized
from a broken leg, right?
That seems crazy.
Speaker 3: No.
Also, you know, we do have a free market health
care system as well.
Right.
Parallel.
So nobody is stopping you from dishing out
the money out of your own pocket.
Yeah, you can even get private health insurance.
You can get the private hospitals.
You can get hospital rooms that are like hotels
if you want to pay for it.
Yes, and that's the big discrepancy.
If you want to pay for it, you can have everything.
But if you want to have it socialized, if
you want to have it free.
Look, if you can afford it, would you rather
wait for it a month to get the hip replacement
or would you rather not get it?
You know, of course.
Of course.
And I can really, I can really feel myself
working up like I'm getting,
Speaker 1: Yeah, Roland, you're getting all
worked up.
You need to go and have a cappuccino.
Speaker 3: Not at this time of day, but I'll
I'll have a nice, smooth, otherwise relaxing
thing.
And that would be nice.
Speaker 1: All right.
Good, Roland from Vienna.
You've really said it all today.
Thanks, David.
All right.
There it is.
Roland from Vienna.
Wow, what a perfect way to cap off phone calls
this week.
I am sorry.
I can't ever get to everyone, but I will try
again when I see you back here next week.